I also wanted to inform you that today
we have sent 1 letter
to the ministry,
to the foreign minister
and also to the government as a whole to ask them to
that publicly and also legally
support this South African initiative
to bring Israel before the international court
of justice, which,
as you know,
is the highest body of justice.
United Nations judicial system
for the crime of genocide.
It seems to us that it is absolutely fundamental that Spain,
which is a party 1 of the States Parties
of the mercury convention,
act as required by this convention
and position yourself favorably
to South Africa's initiative,
that as you know
WILL be rated at 1 View in the next few days,
eh?
This same week at the international court
of justice,
at last 1 country has taken 1 step forward,
has been brave.
South Africa has done well,
but needs the backing
of all countries and needs the backing of Spain.